Sometimes the worst nightmares are the ones
you don’t have.
There are numerous conditions, disorders,
and illnesses that either limit or prevents
the amount of sleep an individual is able
to get.
Many of them are quite dangerous, but none
of them are as frightening or rare as fatal
familial insomnia.
Prion diseases are a category of rare fatal
brain diseases that can strike both humans
and animals.
The disease hits the nervous system and impairs
essential brain functions, which can cause
memory loss, decrease in intelligence, personality
and behavioral changes, and insomnia.
It is caused by an altered and mutated PRNP
gene, inherited from a parent, that manifests
itself in misshapen protein cells that can
pop up in brain tissue.
In humans, there are five known prion diseases:
Creutzfeldt-Jakob Disease, Variant Creutzfeldt-Jakob
Disease, Gerstmann-Straussler-Scheinker Syndrome,
Kuru, and Fatal Familial Insomnia.
There are six known animal prion diseases,
including bovine spongiform encephalopathy,
or more commonly known as “Mad Cow Disease.”
The first prion disease to be identified was
in the 1730s when sheep and goats in Great
Britain started to come down with a mysterious
illness that caused them to be irritable,
lose weight, and become uncoordinated.
The illness, which became known as “Scrapie,”
could kill off whole flocks at a time.
Scrapie was only found in Western Europe for
the first two hundred years of its known existence,
but in the mid-20th century, a Michigan farmer
imported sheep from England and his entire
flock was killed off by the disease.
Today, only Australia and New Zealand are
known to be free from scrapie.
Like all prion diseases, Fatal Familial Insomnia
(FFI) is caused by a change or mutation of
the PRNP gene, which allows it to clump together
in the thalamus region of the brain, eventually
destroying the cells there.
The thalamus region controls sensory and motor
skills, as well as regulation of consciousness
and sleep.
The mutated PRNP gene “eats” holes in
the brain, giving it a “sponge-like” appearance.
This can lead to the inability to sleep (progressively
getting worse overtime) and when sleep is
achieved, very vivid dreams.
It has been observed from EEG readings taken
while the victim is awake show signs associated
with REM sleep.
Essentially, they are so sleep deprived, they
enter a dream-like state when awake.
Other symptoms associated with FFI include
lack of controlled movement or coordination,
as well as personality changes.
Depending on the severity of the symptoms,
it is fatal within months or could persist
(and get worse) for a few years.
The normal life span once diagnosed is 12
to 18 months, but it always leads to death.
Oddly, the first signs and symptoms of FFI
don’t tend to develop until our 40s and
50s.
While no one knows for sure why the gene sits
dormant and does not mutate until then, doctors
have theorized that perhaps it is spurred
on or activated by the vulnerability of the
brain during middle age.
While no one knew it at the time, the first
recorded case of Fatal Familial Insomnia (though,
possibly not the actual first case of it)
was that of a Venetian doctor in 1765.
Originally thought to have died from “an
organic defect of the heart’s sack,” he
suffered from “paralysis” and long bouts
of not sleeping, symptoms that are consistent
with FFI.
Not only that, as documented in the book The
Family That Couldn’t Sleep, he may not have
been the first member of his family to die
this way.
The book goes on to detail the 200 year history
of this Italian family and their battles with
this rare genetic disorder.
There have been other profiled cases of FFI.
In 1991, a Chicago music teacher named Michael
Corke, shortly after his 40th birthday, began
to experience insomnia.
As it got worse and worse, his physical and
mental health began to deteriorate.
He was sent to the University of Chicago hospital
and was wrongly diagnosed with severe depression.
The symptoms got worse and Corke became unable
to sleep at all.
Eventually, doctors induced a coma.
In the end, Corke died six months after the
symptoms began.
Some years later, his case was featured in
the BBC documentary “The Man Who Never Slept.”
It is also unclear if there were others in
Corke’s family who suffered from this disease.
Another interesting story is the one of Vietnam
man Thai Ngoc.
In 2004, he claimed that he hadn’t slept
for 31 years (since 1973) after being stricken
with a bad fever.
Despite over 11,000 sleepless nights, he claimed
that he suffered very little ill physical
or mental effects.
Some have claimed that Ngoc is proof that
Fatal Familial Insomnia isn’t always fatal.
Others, primarily doctors and experts, have
claimed that Ngoc is actually sleeping, he
just doesn’t know it.
According to Dr. Wadhwa, some insomniacs can’t
tell the difference between sleeping and being
awake and engage in very brief “micro-naps”
throughout the day.
While many people fear flying, nobody seems
to fear sleeping in a bed.
Yet in 2013, according to The Aviation Safety
Network, only 265 people around the world
who traveled via a commercial airplane holding
14 or more passengers lost their lives because
of a plane crash (out of about 31 million
flights).
In contrast, in the United States alone, according
to the Center for Disease Control, falling
out of bed accounts for about 450 deaths,
400,000 hospital admissions, and 1.8 million
emergency room visits each year.